advice for people at a large audition
how are you conducting yourself how are
you kind of staying your own space when
you can see all the other actors that oh
they're gonna get it over me and you're
you starting to the tapes or old tapes
are going in the head yes how do you
stay in your own zone how do you focus
how do you conduct yourself for one
thing you'd I never try to start a
conversation with any other actor
there's an actress that I don't see
around so much anymore but I used to see
her a lot and she works she worked a lot
and I work a lot and she knows I do and
when we see each other in an audition
could be me could be her could be one of
the other ten people if you're talking
about a big one but she always starts
talking to me and she's she's I mean
she's not a bad person but we're not
friends by any stretch of the
imagination and I'm not really
interested in her life and I'm sure
she's not really interested in mine but
she chats me up and it's a way of kind
of distracting me from what it is that I
need to focus on so the there's a
process and actors should respect the
process you don't go in chatting away
you don't talk to other actors in full
voice if you have someone that you know
that you've seen that it's nice to see
them again you give them a hug and
whatever and then you give them their
space and and you do not make phone
calls you do not you know you don't you
don't make a lot of noise in the room I
always try to find a place off you know
walk in the hallway I like to stay on my
feet rather than sit for the most part
sometimes the area in which you're
waiting is kind of restrictive but I
always try to find space of my own and
the one thing that it's hard to get rid
of are the tapes that run in your head
that you referred to you know that oh
they're gonna get it oh this or that the
you do not know you none of us know
who's going to get it or why they got it
unless it's you know oftentimes you get
a job because you look the part
you know if if somebody and sometimes
it's decided before you even open your
mouth and the audition you walk in the
room and three people in the room they
said well that no that's not who I see
you know you could be brilliant you
could be Meryl Streep in with your
talent level and you just don't look
like what it is that somebody has their
mind set on you're not in that family of
look and so you're you didn't get it but
you didn't get it before you spoke so it
wasn't your work that you know it wasn't
your audition it was something else so
you can't it's very discouraging though
on those days when you walk in for and
everybody's dressed exactly like you are
know everybody in the room and you see
people who have done this before people
with more experience the new or less and
but it it's so the audition is a real
mind scrambler for many many actors even
very very talented actors Dustin Hoffman
there is a famous story about him
auditioning for the Graduate and and
that little when when he does the
seduction scene with mrs. Robinson you
know that little kind of sound that he
made was the sound he made in his
audition because he was so nervous but
it but they liked what he did and they
and they used it you know so and it's a
auditioning is a very hard thing because
because we put everything on it we put
all our eggs in that basket and so so
it's it's the difficult situation but
when you go there in order to make it
you just respect the process you let the
other actors do their thing if
somebody's talking and you feel like it
asked them to quiet down or if you leave
the room and you can that's that's fine
but I often see a couple of actors just
who haven't seen each other in a while
and they're just catching up and
chatting like they're having coffee and
it
messes with everybody else in the room
because we're focusing on what it is
that we want to do and we'll make sure
we get that done in the room so it's
again it's just common courtesy you used
a phrase earlier which I wish I had used
and I think I did actually use it in the
book the acceptable level of discourtesy
that this is so prevalent in this town
and so it's just do unto others as you
would do they did unto you you know be
quiet let them have their space
don't don't muck about with it just do
your job and then with the cast casting
director how are how are you conducting
yourself like suppose they're like you
know okay Robin next yeah and you're you
come in you slate your name or well I
always like to try to ask a question
makes it finds even if you don't really
have a question ask a question because
it allows you to be yourself and so in
what about this moment and they get to
see you it you know now here are you
going for is she really does she mean
don't come back again or or not you know
ask them something so they see a little
bit of who you are naturally and it
breaks the ice in the room a little bit
and you're not just the dancing monkey
that comes in to do that you know to
behave for them to perform for them so
you take a little of the space for
yourself and do your thing and then it's
over are you thanking them and you turn
on your heel and you're out the door
yes okay I don't know chitchat oh no if
they if they start something I'll say
something and sometimes I say do you
want to see it any other way
and but then who told me one of my New
York agents said to me don't ask them
that it implies that maybe you didn't do
it right the first time so I must admit
I've dialed back on that do you want to
see it any other way but I still ask the
question sometimes but it's generates
thank you very much
and
I still do ask sometimes because I love
to get Direction I love it and listen as
an actor if you've if somebody says to
you I want to see it another way and
they give you direction count your lucky
stars because that's a fabulous thing
because if you can show facility for
taking Direction if you can change what
you did and follow their direction
you've just risen a little peg on their
particular peg pole of what you have to
offer you know right because he realized
that that's going to be you on set if
they yes yeah and that you can see
things another way and sometimes I will
go in and say you know I've made some
sometimes they say do you have any
questions and I will if I if I am pretty
solid and the selections that I've made
I'll say no I just want you to know I
made a choice about how it is I'm gonna
do it but if you want to see it any
other way
afterwards I'm happy to do that and then
I do my thing and then sometimes they
ask to see it another way and sometimes
they don't and sometimes they get the
job and sometimes that
you